hey guys I'm just McDonald and it is
friday the fourteenth of March which
means I've got my top five favorite
stories of the week for you let's crack
into it Microsoft have got themselves
into a bit of hot water this week as we
found out they're planning on putting
targeted political ads into xbox live
The Washington Post reports that the
publishers officials were handing out
promotional materials for political ads
at the Conservative Political Action
Conference so plan is to use players
data to target ads demographically which
will be situated on the live dashboard
according to the report Microsoft has
placed an emphasis on its ability to
reach certain demographic groups
including women Latinos and Millennials
is this your standard money-making
Avenue or do you take concern with the
move let me know next up with those to
have some more to say about the Elder
Scrolls online subscription fee but you
guys are still finding it to be a pretty
hard pill to swallow the dead promises
that the MMO will give players a value
proposition in return for the sea which
won't simply be a noose order a funny
hat if you don't remember that
subscription fee currently sits at a
pretty meaty fifteen dollars a month but
Bethesda says they will be supporting
players with extensive contents that
will feel like regular and consistent
DLC releases when asked about a
free-to-play model Bethesda exact Pete
Hines said it would have created a
lesser game and they wanted to make the
best game possible with evolving content
in news is a bit sad but has become an
awfully prevalent pattern The Witcher 3
has been delayed CD Projekt RED
announced the news to their fans in an
open letter saying it was a very
difficult decision but a necessary one
as of now the game has been pushed back
to februari of 2015 for xbox one ps4 and
PC the death has said that the extra
time will allow them to make a higher
quality game that is uncompromised in
terms of the ambitious game they wanted
to make
according to Ubisoft watchdogs looks
just as good now as it did at e3 despite
claims that it's deteriorated in visual
quality ubisoft's Tessa villain has said
it's not downgraded at all spider gift
found on narrow gap which suggested the
game had been scaled back in graphical
fidelity villain promises that the claim
is false and the watchdog does look like
a true next-gen game speaking of
next-gen games Microsoft have said the
Titan ball is a game changer that will
sell xbox ones while it's certainly one
of this year's blockbuster games Xbox
exact Yusuf Mehdi has said it's hard to
overstate the importance of titanfall to
the xbox one release this year the
publisher are all set for the Maki
shooter to prove to be a big system
seller which it really should be given
the console exclusivity and the fact
that it's the focus of a
five-hundred-dollar Xbox one bundle let
me know in the comments which game of
this year you reckon we'll top sales
charts or you can do so on my Twitter if
you're so inclined this week on site
check out serene and I scared witless by
flying chairs catch cams coverage of
virtual reality devices and ship
yourself off to space with skyrim mods
those are all the things that I've got
for you this week but be sure to join me
again next week for more of the newsie
things and have a great weekend until
then
you